Hi, I'm here with Pete Koomen,
who's a cofounder of Optimizely.
Pete, could you tell me a little
bit about what Optimizely does?
>> Yeah, we make it easy for
our customers to optimize and
personalize the experience they give
their customers on their web site or
mobile applications.
>> Fantastic, and
what's one of your favorite memories
from early on at Optimizely?
>> There are a lot.
I think probably the one I'm
most proud of is when we helped
the Clinton Bush Haiti campaign
raise a lot of money for
earthquake victims in 2010.
So Dan, my co-founder, and I were coming
off the back of two startup failures,
and we had just started
working on Optimizely, and
we were building an easier way to
run A/B tests on your website.
And a few weeks into the project,
we got a call from somebody on a newly
set-up organization, the Clinton Bush
Haiti Fund that was created to try and
raise money for the victims of
this horrible earthquake in Haiti.
And they had one beleaguered IT guy
I think who built this website and
was struggling to keep it up.
And they were getting hundreds of
thousands of visitors every day.
And they called us because they had
worked with Dan on the Obama campaign
in 2008 and
they wanted to improve the website.
They wanted to earn more money for these
earthquake victims from the website.
And so over the course of several days,
we barely slept at all, we built
the beginnings of our platform and
then we ran a bunch of A/B
tests on their website.
What I mean by that is that we
took a look at their website, and
came up with hypotheses of how
could we make this better.
And maybe it's adding an image of
earthquake victims next to the credit
card form, or changing the layout,
or making the text more readable.
And after a whole bunch of these
experiments, we were able to measure
that this particular change actually
improved the conversion rate.
This one harmed it.
This one improved it.
And we were able to actually
raise their dollars per eyeball,
essentially, by 10%.
And so we actually helped them
raise an extra million dollars for
the victims of the earthquake.
>> That's incredible.